all right let's bring out your
amazing Nat wolf
everybody
[Music]
bee such a hi
hottie hi it's so good to see you yeah
oh my God I am obsessed with this movie
because it really is about you know
we're we've been told don't open those X
Files this is the opposite this film I
feel like is kind of a how to guide for
how we should look at what our patterns
and behaviors and life
experiences have led us to but why is it
important to look at your previous
relationships and behavior in history I
think one of the beautiful things about
this movie is that when they're going
back to look at their previous history
they're H they're building compassion
for themselves you know and and and then
in that way they're able to love because
they can forgive themselves and heal
through going through their past
relationship I have spoken to um a lot
of my ex-boyfriends who I'm still really
close with and had those conversations
of like I'm sorry that I was such a
partyer while we were together that
could not have I love accountability
that's so big of you that's hard a lot
of people don't actually take that step
have you ever done that with anyone I
have I feel like I've held myself
accountable and forgiven with
needed um I'm not friends with all of my
exes and by the way there are some you
need to run close those shs are you are
you friends I just went to my ex's
wedding and that was pretty exciting no
way how was that it was amazing it was
amazing I got immediately when I walked
in I had somebody say Uhn Wolf the ex an
evolved man and then they all cheers to
me and somebody came they like are you
the ex stop yeah that's big of you I
love that that's a celebration of one
one's history
have you ever had to go and kind of
explain something that you've changed
about yourself with an ex so the the ex
that I had a really bad kind of falling
out with I I I ran she she hit me with
her car and I banged on the hood no no
completely accidentally just ran it was
like the beginning of a ROM convers and
were you in your car no I was just
walking I was just walking you know
completely I'm totally fine and we no we
ended up having a great conversation and
I was like I'm sorry for my part she
said I'm sorry for her part and now
we're friendly too and twist is it's me
I hit him with well can we play a game
one of my favorites it's called pop
quins and the balloons are going to come
[Applause]
down so what do we
do okay so you prick um your balloon and
there's a question inside of
it I'm I don't know why this okay who
okay I'll give you that does that say it
says oh tell us about your first kiss it
was with David Mitchell and I was um at
youth group I was at church in Tennessee
and I and I looked at him and I think or
I like passed him a note because there
was a a section like behind a brick wall
where everyone would go and make out and
he said yeah and it happened and I
actually I actually Googled him the
other day cuz I was wondering what he
was up to I'm from Tennessee so I'm sure
he's happily married with kids but hi
he's in the audience right
now okay Nat okay there you go there we
go what's your dream meat cute moment I
mean I already did my getting hit by a
car story but maybe in this one it would
be getting it would be the the two cars
they come towards each other they're
driving towards each other really fast
and they step on the brakes and the cars
stop like this and they get out hey are
you okay I'm okay and then and then
that's love right Roman I think you have
an automobile Fe um okay you know what
we'll be right back we're going to come
back with more balloon pop quiin